[Music]
hi there my name is Tina toshko and I'm
a product manager on Google bigquery and
I want to thank everyone for joining on
this session there's just so much
content so many amazing stories to
choose from and so for myself from from
all the other speakers that I'm joining
with I wanna thank you for picking this
session specifically so this session is
all about scale lots of data large
volumes of data complex problems but
it's also about it's about organizations
that have a rich history of Creative
Technology and history of solving
large-scale problems and so what better
way to demonstrate the complexity and
scale of something than to have not one
not two not three not four but five
presenters for a session I think this is
a record for next so all these
organizations have solved tackle
problems for their relatively unique
scale and if you fast-forward 2006 who
had our own technical problems to solve
we couldn't do interactive analytics at
Google scale and that's where German
came along so Dremel for the past ten
plus years has been powering Google data
in analytics infrastructure and bit
quarry as most people in this room
already know the quarry is powered by
Dremel the quarry is Dremel it's the
same or engineering team it's the same
infrastructure the same codebase and so
when you think about it when you're
running bigquery you're running on top
of Google's innovation you're running on
top of Dremel and what what gives
bigquery its scale characteristics is
its native cloud architecture cloud
native architecture is its unique
architectural principles unique
architectural considerations so it
starts with stateless multi-tenant
compute cluster which is really what
Dremel is right which is really unique
offering and there's joined together by
a logical storage system
that scales into petabytes and more and
the tool wired together by our network
that scales to petabytes and then we
started to go beyond that right we with
separate computing state intermediate
state during processing which
accelerates many of our queries gives us
performance durability scalability
characteristics and then we allow to
share data in place without creating
data silos without moving that around
needlessly right you bring analytics to
data you bring users to that and not the
other way around and finally we were out
there all around in a fully managed
offering that minimizes complexity
manageability overheads for your
organization's makes it easy for you
guys to use this type of technology at
scale so there's this really really good
quote by someone I really respect the
query was built for scale it's true I
believe this person and so you don't
have to believe me when you when you
listen to this here's a couple of
anecdotes that I've found on Twitter
from folks who really really appreciate
using the query our queries have gone
from four hours to 13 seconds it's
awesome here's another one I can vouch
for bigquery it's pretty magical so now
I want to discourage folks from from
jumping on Twitter right the second and
prepare in professing your love for
bigquery especially using foul language
please don't do that okay but the next
one is really my favorite perhaps my
favorite Twitter quote of all time it's
from a gentleman who works at Spotify
and two years ago when we started to
work with Spotify this is what he
tweeted finally I can tell the world
that the query is the best thing that
has ever happened to me
I feel like if it's in caps I have to
shout it and mature I mean he he
probably doesn't have a lot of interests
but he's a brilliant engineer and
Spotify has a brilliant organization of
course the delightful product
everyone loves using Spotify but also
incredibly create
technologists and I'd like to please
welcome one of them here on stage with
me Nicole Nicole is going to share the
story of how Spotify is embraced cool
cloud platform and bokurei specifically
for their use cases please
thanks Tina I appreciate the intro hey
everyone thanks for having me here today
I'll start with a brief introduction my
name is Nicole and I work at Spotify in
the as a technical product manager in
the data infrastructure tribe which is
our name for department at Spotify
specifically I work with a team that
works on building tools and to support
big query across Spotify so we work
closely with bigquery everyday we in DI
and as a whole build internal tools and
infrastructure to support data at
Spotify so before I get into this talk I
want to just apologize briefly if I get
a little bit technical feel free to find
me after the talk and I can explain
things a little bit more detail if you
have any questions so I thought I'd
start with a very brief history of the
short history of Spotify in the cloud
which actually now that I think about it
would be a great name for a band
I don't have to do that someday alright
so four years ago when we started the
transition to to the cloud at that point
Spotify was almost completely on-premise
and bare metal we were doing
I think our largest point we had
something like 2500 nodes in our Hadoop
cluster and over 10,000 machines and
four data centers around the world and
what we were finding is that even at
that kind of scale one of the largest
Hadoop clusters in Europe it still
really wasn't enough we are expanding
rapidly in the US and we were really
having trouble keeping up with a growth
in and being able to do our analytical
work and that in particular was a really
big pain point for us running a single
query on this cluster in hive could take
us hours so after a couple years of
small experiments we finally decided to
take the plunge and move to the cloud
and but before I move on I wanted to
give a brief plug to my amazing
colleagues Josh and Ramon he'll be
giving a talk about integration and
tomorrow afternoon so if you have
interest any interest in hearing more
about how we did that migration to the
cloud please listen into their talk
so for us the move to bigquery was
actually a really big success
it was rapidly adopted by the Spotify
analytics and data science community and
to the state still remains one of the
most popular GCP tools we use that
Spotify for us in particular what really
meant for us was that we were getting
fast results we were able to add
capacity a lot easier and we found that
the integration with the other GCP tools
was really help as well one of the
biggest wins for us was really how it
democratized access to data at Spotify
it was really that ease of use meant
that more people could be asking more
questions and getting responses faster
which meant that overall we were getting
a massively shorter time to insite using
sequel particularly as a querying
language was really powerful for letting
people across the company ask questions
of our data in a way that they had never
been able to do before so I thought I'd
give you a quick example of how using
bigquery impacted our ability to ask
questions of our data so this is a kind
of question that somebody in data
scientists might want to be asking how
much time did users in Spain spend
listening to Spotify in October of 2016
before when we were working with hive it
would take us something like 16 minutes
or so to get an answer for this one
question now when we move to bigquery
the same question only takes us about 33
seconds so as you can see a huge sea
change in our ability to get those
answers quickly now if you multiply that
by hundreds of questions asked by
hundreds of people at Spotify daily the
kind of impact this kind of speed is
gonna have is really clear and in case
you guys are wondering the answer to
that question is the total hours or
equivalent nearly ten thousand years all
right so what does it really mean or
what do we mean when we say petabyte
scale what does that really look like
internally and Spotify we sometimes
refer to this as how big is data and our
answer for that is really really big so
right now
Spotify has about 770 million active
users listening to our catalogue of over
35 million songs
in 65 different markets so as you can
probably imagine we have generate a lot
of data and being able to ant
ask the right questions in the right way
becomes really important to us
and so that's what we end up using
bigquery for so we use bigquery to do
that kind of analysis at a scale that
we've never been able to do before
right now we have about 25 percent of
employees at bigquery that are using
bigquery on a regular basis either
directly or through custom tooling on
top of bigquery we process around 400
petabytes of data monthly and store over
a hundred petabytes of data specifically
in bigquery doesn't even talk about
things we're storing in other parts the
GCB
product suite and that also includes
loading and around 500 terabytes of new
data daily into bigquery and what that
means is that in total we end up running
around 6 million queries a month so
that's a really big scale so for us that
moved to bigquery has actually solved a
lot of the issues that we used to have
in our old clusters but as we grown we
really had to develop new techniques to
ensure that we're going to continue to
be successful for us we actually see
this as a big win we've moved beyond
those lower level problems of you know
we even get the answers we need to the
higher-level questions of how do we
continue to ensure good performance if
our data doubles in size again so I
thought I'd start with a few things here
that we've discovered over the past year
that have helped us a scale effectively
in bigquery we found that the things
we're doing fall into four kind of
categories the first being
administration managing how bigquery is
being used across the company second one
is around education learning about how
to tune our bigquery performance to get
the best results
third is integration that's leveraging
the api's and other GCP products to get
the right tool for the right time and
then finally we have working closely
with Google to improve bigquery so
working on a partnership with them
someone dig a little bit deeper into
each of those first of all when we talk
about the the kinds of things we were
doing and administration to be
successful one of the first things we
did was move to
capacity model this has been really
helpful to us because we have ensures
that we have dedicated slots and helps
us be predictable with our costs that's
been a big win for us it does mean we
need to think a little bit ahead to
enable to grow our capacity but we've
been finding that it's actually
significantly still better than the
problems we were having in our
on-premise Hadoop clusters for growing
capacity we still have a significantly
faster speed of growth there the second
thing we do is we've been creating sub
reservations which are kind of smaller
pools within our larger reservation that
allows us to isolate jobs and business
critical projects and that's actually
been really helpful for us particularly
because we regularly rebalance which
projects have access to which pools and
that means that we're getting the best
performance for the right time a good
example of this is whenever we're gonna
do a large backfill on our data so if
they went wrong or we need to add some
data into a table that already exists we
will move that particular project into
its own sub reservation with an isolated
set of resources that it can use and
that means it's preventing preventing
that from impacting the day to day work
everybody else but also ensuring that
that particular job has the resources
and needs to complete on time that's
been really powerful for us we also make
sure that business critical projects are
in their own sub reservation that means
no matter what happens they're always
going to have access to the resources
they need to complete those business
critical tasks the next thing we've been
working on has to do with education
specifically learning how to tune our
performance as being one of the main
things for us what that really means is
learning how do we need to manage our
concurrency how do we use batch vs.
interactive mode to help figure out when
jobs should run these kinds of things
help us ensure that we're getting the
best performance when we're running
things on bigquery the second thing we
been learning a lot about is the impact
of Dremel architecture understanding
that it's not a relational database and
that using a colon or datastore actually
provides significant benefits for
certain
two queries but could be very different
and not work as well for other kinds of
queries and so ensuring that people who
are running queries on bigquery across
the company really understand how to
optimize for the kind of architecture
they're running on and finally the thing
we do in within Spotify is we have a
very passionate community of bigquery
users and we leverage that a lot to help
share best practices around the company
next we work on integration specifically
we use bigquery API wrappers to allow us
to build our own set of custom tools on
top of bigquery to meet our own needs
this really allows us to but to do
deeper integration with our own tools
and environment while still averaging
that power of bigquery behind the scenes
behind that that's been really helpful
for us to continue growing and
fine-tuning something for our specific
needs we also leverage other leverage
the integrations with other Google cloud
data products and specifically the
ability to move data between different
products easily that allows us to really
optimize about using the right tool for
the job
finally we focus on building a good
partnership specifically with the Google
bigquery team as well with our strategic
cloud Engineering's
engineers that work with us here at
Spotify we work with them really to help
keep expanding the features and
capabilities of bigquery
that you really need to be able to
operate at this kind of scale what that
means for us on a day-to-day basis is
that we're talking with them about
feature requests you know as we're
pushing the limits of what bigquery does
right now we work closely in telling
them hey these the new features we need
this is where we'd like to see this grow
a great example of this for us is not
too long ago we were working on becoming
ready for gdpr the general data
protection regulation that rolled out in
Europe a few months ago and we realized
that the technique we were using for
encryption and decryption just wasn't
going to scale to the extent we needed
for for gdpr compliance so we work
closely with the bigquery team to work
on new tools and features that allow us
to do that at the ski
we needed to if the speed we needed to
do as well that's been really helpful
and then finally we've been working
closely with the support team at Google
to help us with troubleshooting
specifically whenever we run into any
issues or users have challenges we or we
have performance issues we're able to
really reach out and get quick responses
and solve our problems very smoothly and
that's if for me I'm gonna pass that
over to tea now to talk about the next
[Applause]
we're good
Thank You Nicole that was that was
fantastic so Spotify has you know at one
point in time before moving to Google
cloud platform Spotify had the largest
Hadoop cluster in Europe or right up
there and highly tuned they spent a lot
of time thinking about performance and
operational complexity and you know now
they're working with us to solve the
problems which gives them an opportunity
to to focus on delighting their
customers rather than trying to tweak
certain HDFS variables or things that
they may not think are important for
their business
well Spotify has been with us for three
years now but I'd like to welcome on
stage our next customer here our next
speaker at 1 from both you have probably
used you probably use a property of both
every single day in your life so and
they all has been with us on stage last
time and they've kind of grown since
then so it's really intersting to see
the progression of where they're going
and where they're going to be next one
please
Thank You Tina it's like he said my name
is Tom Tom and that a technical director
at oath on the media and analytics
warehouse team also known as ma and for
those of you are not familiar as
familiar with oath it was basically
formed last year after Verizon's
acquisition of Yahoo which merges
together with AOL and that formed a kind
of house of brands represented here by
what we like to show his orbs not an
exhaustive list but we have a lot of
well-known properties products including
huffington post flurry tumblr TechCrunch
and Engadget to name a few
so when we talk about media analytics
both what we're really talking about is
scale in terms of volume and velocity of
data we've spent the last year working
with all the brands from the merger
trying to from around the world and
across their platforms conforming their
data and to bring it together and
presents a uniform business view of our
company we also try to serve a wide
range of users and use cases we provide
KPI reporting for executives product
metrics for product managers and
engineers and then we also support
editors by providing real-time Afternoon
information on the performance of their
content and so to satisfy all these use
cases we try to strive to provide a
single cell service interactive and
scalable data platform so get a little
history about how we got to this point
and before we had bigquery generally at
companies we start with analytics he
started small you have a single pipeline
presenting the data to panelists and
then you bring on more products you have
more requirements and you started to add
another stack another warehouse
companies grow you acquire other
businesses that bring in their own
warehouses these warehouses the inside
they interact with each other and you
have to kind of reconcile that
information so you kind of land at a
picture that looks kind of like this you
have a lot of specialized data store
have evolved into data silos you have a
lot of engineering teams kind of
repeating work which is not very
cost-efficient you load data into
multiple places using different logic to
process it sometimes yielding different
results and then those differences
eventually have to be reconciled somehow
you have the version text ax that starts
to evolve they use technology is just
like relational databases that when you
reach a certain threshold can't maintain
with the pace of the services required
and so overall you have a very poor
foundation for building an analytics
platform so what was the solution
so Yahoo obviously being a huge
contributor to Hadoop
had the expertise to build out large
scale clusters for storing data large
ETL pipelines you know we have clusters
in tens of thousands of nodes so that
was not the issue and what we really
needed was a complimentary service that
could take that data expose it make it
interactive scale it with the needs of
the business and then also be kind of
cost-efficient and so for us that
solution was bigquery we use that as the
basis for our new architecture it's able
to scale with the needs that's brought
on all the brands from our merger it's
flexible nothing terms of capabilities
to satisfy two different use cases that
we have for our users
it's a managed platform so it brings
lower operational overheads and so it
maintains a relatively lower cost for us
as well so initially when we started our
pipeline it was a very basic hadoop
design we ingested our log data and
event data into our cluster process that
with high with pig stage it up in hive
and then service it to our end users
through our bi analytics front-end tool
which is liquor and this serve this
purpose when we started off and if you
remember the original chain when you
start small everything works fine and as
Nicole said they started with hive as
well but as the demands grew hive
couldn't keep up with the services that
we needed to provide
so I'm looking at alternatives we
started to look at bigquery and actually
this diagram was presented at last
year's conference by my colleague Nikhil
Mishra as our first step for introducing
bigquery we wanted to take a very
measured approach for adopting into our
platform this gave us the opportunity to
work with the dev team to understand the
GCP environment to understand how that
works we are clouding or our Hadoop
environment let us understand the
capabilities and the shortcomings of the
tools and be able to figure out the
right way to integrate it we left it in
there along with hive and still serving
the data up through a bigquery looker so
that our end users really didn't
experience any difference in their
service except maybe some possible gains
in performance and some functionality
and then it led to our current design
represented here I think the biggest
thing you can notice is all the data now
is being served up through bigquery
we've greatly increased the capacity
that we store in there because we have
brought in all this data and all the
brands from our merger we've added in a
real-time pipeline in our system which
allows us to take advantage of bigquery
streaming ingestion capabilities we've
also started to take advantage of
additional GCP services like pub/sub
data flow and data prop because of how
well they work together inside of that
ecosystem and really this overall
presents a simpler design for the
overall architecture that we're trying
to achieve and like I said that
architecture afforded us the ability to
simplify the design we've gotten rid of
all those specialized data stores and
data silos we're able to unify things
like the streaming and real and batch
pipelines so that all our logic is
centralized in a single location we had
the flexibility in terms of services on
to provide the data we've added our own
API on top of bigquery API so we could
provide programmatic access to our users
that require that and as the needs
require we can scale up both storage and
compute to meet the satisfy their needs
as they grow
and here the numbers can speak for
themselves in terms of the amount of
storage we have the number of users the
amount of usage that users apply in
terms of queries against our services
and really the the numbers kind of speak
to the significance of our system kind
of the importance of it providing value
for our company and the day-to-day
decisions that our colleagues need to
make I think the numbers also speak to
the validity of our choice in using
bigquery as the backbone over here
infrastructure because it has been able
to grow to match the needs and demands
of our services so a couple learnings
that we've had along the way as
mentioned before GDP are as well I'm
sure of a lot of us had to face that new
regulation that took effect earlier this
year which is so enjoyable but for us it
really presented a very daunting
proposition of having to restate
petabytes of data within our warehouse
at a fairly frequent rate which would
been very time-consuming very resource
consuming obviously very costly and so
we had to find alternatives to handle
that and looking at those we were able
to settle using a bigquery DML and what
that allowed us to do is to apply
massive scale updates and deletes on our
data it didn't require us to do any
additional work in terms of reprocessing
the data or having the restage our data
everything we said that the functions
were very performant to meet our
expectations we did work cooperatively
with the dev team to get enhancements
along the way like being able to apply
DML to streaming tables which is one of
our requirements and we can't continue
to work with the dev team to try to
improve the process by looking at things
such as clustering which we expect
they're going to yield additional
performance gains
in terms of streaming obviously being
able to ingest event level data into
your warehouse is a huge advantage and
for us we kind of applied a lambda
architectural we overlay the real-time
data with batch data and so if you're
querying for the last 10 minutes or the
last 10 weeks of data you're going to
the same table using the same query
essentially but it makes you think in
different aspects so yet then to think
in terms of quotas and inputs amount of
events and the size of those events of
course nothing comes for free so what we
experienced with tables with heavy
streaming ingestion there's gonna be
some performance impacts in terms of
queries so we had the work to kind of
either overcome or be able to work with
the situations so in some cases we use
on-prem Hardware to offset some of that
in other cases we're looking at
alternatives like micro batching
ingestion which we're hoping will
increase performance of those situations
I think the really biggest discovery for
us is the Independence of the quotas for
a lot of the things that you can
configure streaming ingestion quotas
versus batch ingestion quarters don't
impact each other
querying as well as ingestion quotas
don't impact each other and what it
really gives you is a lot of flexibility
a lot of on-demand flexibility to
configure your situation especially in
highly dynamic situation environments so
you can handle any event that comes to
you and be able to handle those
accordingly
so in the media business we kind of
allowed a high-profile high-volume
events there's late-breaking news
there's live sporting events and so we
went in an arrangement with the NFL to
stream their contents and it was decided
that we wanted to provide real-time
metrics around the performance of that
streaming and for us that meant
experience Peaks involve in terms of
events and size of days that we don't
typically have to encounter so in
looking alternatives to satisfy those
requirements using the hardware route we
really didn't have the runway to procure
set up the hardware not to mention what
do you do with a hardware after the
event is completed and so we look to
bigquery being able to dynamically
increase our quotas meet the
expectations of the events turn down the
quotas at the end of that and the best
thing of all is you only pay for what
you use during that time we were able to
handle that engagement with with no
issues in a very short amount of time
and so overall it was a very successful
engagement so what are we looking to do
from here obviously we want to continue
to unlock the value of data that we
expose in our platform we're going to
increase the volume look at additional
data sets they could provide value for
other parts of the company looking at
additional GCP services like machine
language being able to do things like
user segmentation and clustering in that
platform and then we're working with the
bigquery team at Google on pre releases
and alpha beta versions of additional
features which I won't mention here have
to take a way to Thunder from T no
company but they'll be announcing of
those I think shortly tomorrow and with
that I'm done take it so on
I will take everything again thank you
so much fun so the impact of that NFL
game event shouldn't be understated at
warning coke came to us said hey guys
we're gonna forget this NFL game going
on and we're gonna stream four gigabytes
per second into your streaming system
and you know we freaked out a little bit
at first but you know over over they
gave us enough free time and we
delivered it the important thing to note
is that all the complexity was on our
side right old all Tuan's team was
looking at is an API surface right so we
went out there and we we made sure there
everything would work right our sorry's
were on call everyone was very happy
with the outcome
and they just sent rose to us so and
then they paid for only what they
consumed so it's a great story and the
other color I would say is as you get to
these scales the anti-pattern space
expands dramatically there are so many
things that are unknowns that you have
to do you encounter for the first time
do you have to fix so so folks like
Spotify and folks like both you know the
problems that that they face and they
work with us to resolve straight in our
system so people who aren't necessarily
at that scale get a more robust more
performant system well now I'm gonna
kind of change the gears a little bit
Spotify and I've been with us for a
while they're operating at huge scale
but we have a newcomer into our platform
believe in April Twitter announced that
they chose Google cloud platform as
their vendor of choice or a cloud cloud
vendor of choice to host their next
generation data analytics platform so
that's early for them but they're
already getting some results so I'd like
to welcome a couple of Engineers from
Twitter who are going to be talking
about how they're using bigquery today
please welcome Pawan and Robin
Thank You Tina
hey there I'm Pawan in M Roman we're
from the revenue platform team at
Twitter and today we're going to talk
about some of the compelling technical
challenges we faced recently how
bigquery helped us solved them and where
we go next
so a Twitter we have a track record of
victories solving some of the problems
that have been impossible to sell before
and and we really really want to tell a
story of how we start using bigquery and
what drove us to get here 10 billion
advertise events process daily so this
is the skill we have to deal with and
and what happens to this skill when
something goes wrong it's really hard to
tell so we had a need to write arbitrary
queries against our data sets to answer
some of those questions and for a lot of
our data sources we own it's even
impossible or extremely time-consuming
so with that in mind I want to share one
or II will turn real life cases so two
quarters ago we had a bug someone
reported we showed the wrong F we showed
ads to the wrong user something we
should never do so first steps identify
if there are any other campaigns that
were affected fortunately we have tools
to do that it's called business audit
records any change made to a campaign
gets logged into this table and my
sequel and so all you have to do is to
query it turns out it's really hard to
do at our scale
I own one or Twitter's largest my Seco
dusters and this is one of its largest
tables you can literally hear my seagull
scream and pain when you're trying to
query a 3.2 billion row table so how
long did it take for us to finally ask
answer the question were there any other
campaigns that were affected it took us
two weeks it took us two weeks for
engineers the DBA and a whole lot of
pain to finally answer the question how
could we do better the platform team the
data platform team has been
experimenting with bigquery for a while
and we thought it was the perfect
technology to help solve our problem
with the power of BQ blaster that Roman
is going to talk about next our data was
ingested in no time and now things are
as simple as writing sequel but without
the timeouts this takes less than a
minute to execute and this was just one
use case so we looked at this use case
and a couple of other test cases and we
really serve potential to answer
questions in more depth if we move all
our data sources to bickering and here's
where it becomes a really hard
engineering problem how do we generalize
the ingestion regardless of the source
and that's kale it was never an easy
transition for us big worry alone was
not enough and we really had to build a
set of tools to enable those experiments
to see what queries we can run and also
what new questions we could get answer
it the career blaster obq blaster how a
call for short is one of the first tool
that were built for this and let's see
what it does
we started with introspection on our own
systems and with so many with so many
data sources and database tabs we really
wanted to build a tool that would have
structurally the original data source so
the initiator for this would be a
scouting job that picks up the data from
any original source that we have and
lands in a Google Cloud storage the very
last step is a bigquery import job that
picks up data from Google Cloud storage
and allows it straight to be a table so
this is a tool in our show we also want
to talk about where we go next so we
took the learnings from this initiative
and are applying it to our next
challenge getting the data organization
right we consume more than hundred
terabyte data Rev of Revenue logs per
day moving all this Ruby query is our
next challenge and we know how to tackle
this now thank you
[Applause]
thank you guys
so we you've heard some of the stories
of folks who are doing interesting
things at scale who have lots of data
but I don't want to give you the
impression that this is the only thing
that the query is good at the query is
has a wide wide range of customers of
all scales and all sizes and all types
of complexities so much so that the vast
majority of our customers are actually
using our perpetual free tier you get 10
gigabytes of storage and one terabyte of
data processed every single month for
free right so if you have that much data
you never have to pay us a penny and so
we would encourage you to try it out if
you haven't yet because it might be a
great tool for your use case no matter
how big or small and of course you can
go take a look at cloud.google.com slash
free to get your $300 credits that you
can use on bigquery or any other product
that you may like and of course you can
take a look at some of the other
sessions that we have we have lots of
customers talking about how they're
using our infrastructure and our
services it's a very varying style of
use cases so you can get a variety of
you can experience a variety of what
people are talking about
you
[Music]